[Applaudissements]
écoutez moi tout ce qui fait la musique
car actuellement pendant la pause on ne
va pas se mentir jean michel maire est
allé aux toilettes donc ils pensaient
qu'on allait pas reprendre sans lui
c'était mal nous connaît il ne le sait
pas et quand il va revenir vous allez
lui et mekouar a permis
néanmoins je trouve que ça dure quand
même depuis lors et en l'état des
toilettes
il faudra lui demander si c'était la
petite la grosse prévention
ces questions kepa sac et est ce que tu
t'es laver les mains non mais qu'est ce
qui vous a pris pourquoi ç'a duré si
longtemps mais non vie c'est à partir
d'un certain âge
bah non c'est pas vrai s'est pas lavé
les mains
[Applaudissements]